well Russian missile strikes on
Ukraine's capital and other cities have
killed at least one person and injured
dozens more explosions were heard in
keev and the eastern city of H Targets
in the South and West were also hit well
let's get more now from ID bag who joins
us live from keev Russia once again
hitting the heart of Ukraine how
extensive is this latest
attack well it seems to be one of the
largest uh attacks for a while now they
started in the early hours of the
morning uh this the sounds of explosions
rang out across the capital uh we saw
some of the anti-aircraft fire go up we
heard the explosions but also what's
significant is there have been some
impacts in the capital now the mayor of
ke vital Klitschko has said that several
areas in the capital have been hit and
people have been injured the authorities
here have urged people to stay in their
shelters in fact actually as we speak
the air alert is still on telling people
to go to their shelters now the second
largest city K the mayor there has said
that there has been a massive attack and
there have been targets hit in the
center we understand that there are some
casualties there the mayor of K said
that being outside is not safe and urged
people to stay in their shelters now
What's significant is that Captain ha ke
tends to have the better air defenses uh
but they were working from the early
hours of the morning but they the
missile strikes still managed to get
through we understand that there are
fire Crews at several scenes now from
the authorities here we only tend to
hear when nonmilitary targets are hit so
when civilian infrastructure is hit they
don't tell us when military targets are
hit but this uh these attacks have been
going on now since the 29th of December
but at least here in the capital ke this
has been one of the largest attacks that
we have seen for a while the buildings
were shaking you could see the flash of
the explosions and the impacts taking
place across the city mm I said like you
say this has been one of the largest
attacks in recent times what has been
the reaction from residents
there well people have been shocked we
haven't seen in the morning we tend to
see people outside walking their dogs uh
but many people are in their shelters
right now we understand they are parts
of the city without electricity and
mobile connection like I said generally
the KE tends to have better air defenses
but this morning there have been SS of
explosions there's been smoke Rising
into the air there's been sound uh
sounds of the Sirens of the Rescue
Services rushing to those sites to try
and get to people uh that may have been
affected uh so this is one of the
largest and most extensive strikes and
if I take you back to the 29th of
December where Russia struck targets
across the country in what the
authorities said was the most massive
aerial assault since the early days of
the war and there seems to be no letup
uh in Russian air strikes currently okay
thanks so much for that update acid bake
for us there in ke